Okay, let's give it another minute for folks to join, then we'll get going.
Alright, I think we've got most people — I see Dana, Naomi, Ben, Marcus, James. Let's get started.
Can everyone see my screen alright?
Yep, looks good.
Quick agenda: I want to get through the main topic, leave room for questions, and land on clear action items before we drop. Sound good?
Before the main topic, let's do a fast round — where's everyone at? Keep it short.
Quick status: the CARE governance framework. On track. I might need a review later but nothing urgent.
On my side, the roadmap and keeping the two tracks in sync is moving along — made good progress this week, nothing blocking.
Can we double-check that against what we agreed last week?
I'll take that one — it's adjacent to community review and the advisory process anyway.
Just flagging that this touches the CARE governance framework, so loop me in when it firms up.
Good point — let's do that.
Yeah, exactly.
the manifest schema and validator — steady. One open question I'll raise when we get to it, otherwise fine.
That matches what I was seeing on my end with the manifest schema and validator.
Just flagging that this touches the manifest schema and validator, so loop me in when it firms up.
Okay, works for me.
I want to make sure I understand the tradeoff before we commit to anything.
Can we double-check that against what we agreed last week?
Mm, let me sit with that one.
Right, that's what I meant.
That matches what I was seeing on my end with community review and the advisory process.
Do we actually need a decision on this today, or can it wait a week?
That matches what I was seeing on my end with the label renderer and the validator tests.
That's fair.
I've been heads-down on the label renderer and the validator tests. It's mostly there; I'll have the next piece up in a couple of days.
Do we actually need a decision on this today, or can it wait a week?
Right, that's what I meant.
How does this interact with the backend capability model and the provenance schema, if at all?
On my side, the backend capability model and the provenance schema is moving along — made good progress this week, nothing blocking.
Let me play that back to make sure we're all aligned on it.
I don't feel strongly on this one — I'll defer to whoever owns it.
Good point — let's do that.
Good — as long as it's reversible, I'm comfortable moving.
Not much to report on community review and the advisory process beyond steady progress. I'll flag it if that changes.
One concern and then I'll drop it: are we sure about the sequencing here?
Mm, let me sit with that one.
I don't feel strongly on this one — I'll defer to whoever owns it.
Do we actually need a decision on this today, or can it wait a week?
Let's confirm in the channel.
Agreed, let's capture it.
That matches what I was seeing on my end with the roadmap and keeping the two tracks in sync.
I'm a little worried about the timeline, but I'm not blocking on it.
Let's confirm in the channel.
Can we make sure that lands as an action item so it doesn't get lost?
Just flagging that this touches the backend capability model and the provenance schema, so loop me in when it firms up.
Sure, I can own that.
Can someone capture that in the notes close to verbatim?
Okay, works for me.
Can we make sure that lands as an action item so it doesn't get lost?
Let me play that back to make sure we're all aligned on it.
Makes sense to me.
Yeah, that's consistent with what we talked about in the last sync.
Okay, works for me.
Good — as long as it's reversible, I'm comfortable moving.
I don't feel strongly on this one — I'll defer to whoever owns it.
I'd rather over-communicate here — can we write down who's doing what?
One concern and then I'll drop it: are we sure about the sequencing here?
Q3 retro. Round-robin as always. The numbers are in the tool, but I want the human read. Dana?
How does this interact with the backend capability model and the provenance schema, if at all?
Let's confirm in the channel.
My airtime went from about two-thirds to under 40%. The nudges did what I couldn't do by watching myself. That's the honest headline.
How does this interact with community review and the advisory process, if at all?
That's fair.
Sure.
Can we make sure that lands as an action item so it doesn't get lost?
I speak in meetings now. Not because I changed, because the format did — pre-reads and round-robin. The silence in Q2 was a design problem, not a me problem.
Same-day on the August regression instead of four days. And I defended a design in review and survived it.
Can we make sure that lands as an action item so it doesn't get lost?
Mm-hm.
Let's move to the next item.
Let me share my screen so we're all looking at the same thing.
One concern and then I'll drop it: are we sure about the sequencing here?
That's fair. I'll withdraw the concern.
Sure, I can own that.
Yeah, exactly.
I don't feel strongly on this one — I'll defer to whoever owns it.
Right, and that lines up with the constraint we set at kickoff.
Mm, let me sit with that one.
Okay, works for me.
Okay, I think I follow. So the plan is basically what you just described.
How does this interact with the manifest schema and validator, if at all?
Agreed, let's capture it.
That's fair. I'll withdraw the concern.
Mm, let me sit with that one.
Can we make sure that lands as an action item so it doesn't get lost?
Sure, I can own that.
I'm a little worried about the timeline, but I'm not blocking on it.
Let's confirm in the channel.
Sorry, can you go back to the point about the review pass?
One concern and then I'll drop it: are we sure about the sequencing here?
I want to make sure I understand the tradeoff before we commit to anything.
Okay, works for me.
Can we make sure that lands as an action item so it doesn't get lost?
Yeah, that's consistent with what we talked about in the last sync.
Can we double-check that against what we agreed last week?
That's fair.
Let me play that back to make sure we're all aligned on it.
Can someone capture that in the notes close to verbatim?
Dissent-before-decision is just how we work now. And the license question never reopened — we actually settled it in June with the snapshot mitigation.
Do we actually need a decision on this today, or can it wait a week?
Yeah, that's consistent with what we talked about in the last sync.
Can you scroll up to the top of that section?
Do we actually need a decision on this today, or can it wait a week?
Sure, I can own that.
Right, and that lines up with the constraint we set at kickoff.
Okay, works for me.
One concern and then I'll drop it: are we sure about the sequencing here?
Sure — one sec.
My one caution: don't let the tool become the point. It's a mirror. The work is still us choosing to look. But it's a good mirror.
Can someone capture that in the notes close to verbatim?
I'm a little worried about the timeline, but I'm not blocking on it.
That matches what I was seeing on my end with the label renderer and the validator tests.
Sure, I can own that.
Yeah, exactly.
Let me pull up the numbers so we're not going off memory.
Action: roll it out to the two partner districts' teams, and publish the before/after so other Alaska teams can use it.
Okay — any questions before we wrap?
Should I loop anyone else in on the the label renderer and the validator tests side, or is that covered?
Good question — let's confirm the specifics in the channel so we don't rathole here.
One thing: how does this affect the the backend capability model and the provenance schema timeline?
Alright, let me read back the action items so we're aligned before we drop.
Sarah has the follow-up on the CARE governance framework — I'll capture the specifics in the notes.
Dana has the follow-up on the roadmap and keeping the two tracks in sync — I'll capture the specifics in the notes.
Naomi has the follow-up on the manifest schema and validator — I'll capture the specifics in the notes.
Great. I'll write it all up and drop it in the channel. Thanks everyone.